nos dicen que la fórmula la fórmula para
encontrar el perímetro de un rectángulo
es igual a 12 l más 2 w donde p es el
perímetro l es el largo y w es el ancho
y para visualizar lo que nos están
pidiendo aunque quizás tú ya estás
familiarizado con esto hagamos aquí un
rectángulo esto parece un rectángulo si
este lado mide l el lado opuesto también
mediría el entonces si este lado de aquí
es el ancho que mide wv el opuesto
también mide w el perímetro es la
distancia que hay que recorrer para
darle una vuelta al rectángulo entonces
ese perímetro lo podemos calcular como
wv más l más
wv más l y aquí si agrupamos los
términos semejantes tenemos w aquí y
doblegó a qui esto es 2 w
más tenemos el de aquí
y el yak a más 2 l y ya tenemos que el
perímetro es 2 l más 2 w accardi la
locución de manera distinta como lo
escribimos nosotros pero al final de
cuentas es la misma fórmula para el
perímetro p y la pregunta es reescribe
la fórmula para encontrar el ancho para
encontrar el ancho la fórmula como la
tenemos ahorita dice p es igual a algo
lo que ellos nos piden es una fórmula
para w una fórmula que nos diga que w es
igual a algo donde van a aparecer p
w y un montón de números hay mezclados
veamos cómo podemos hacer esto nos dicen
nos están dando que p es igual a 2 l más
2 w si queremos una fórmula para
calcular el ancho w
necesitamos despejar w para eso podemos
empezar eliminando la l de este lado de
la ecuación para lograr esto sin que se
altere nuestra ecuación restamos 12 l de
ambos lados de la ecuación
hagámoslo así entonces restamos
y el del lado derecho y también lo
restamos 2l también restamos 2 l del
lado izquierdo
acuérdate aquí arriba teníamos la
ecuación p es igual a 2 l más 2 w si
está restando 12 l de lado derecha
también hay que restarle 2 l ap lo que
hagas de un lado de una ecuación hay que
hacerlo del otro lado de la ecuación
para que no se altere la igualdad que
tenemos entonces del lado izquierdo
nos queda p
- 2 l es igual a es igual a 2 cl menos 2
l se cancelan para eso hicimos todo esto
estos dos términos se cancelan y nos
queda tan solo 2 w y ya casi llegamos ya
casi despejamos w para esto necesitamos
dividir ambos lados de la ecuación entre
2 y la razón de esto de dividir a ambos
lados entre 2 es deshacernos de este
coeficiente 2 de este 2 que está
multiplicando a w
entonces dividiendo ambos lados de la
ecuación entre 2 de nueva cuenta se hace
algo de un lado lo tienes que hacer del
otro lado la razón por la que dividir
entre dos es que 2 x algo dividido entre
2 nos da ese algo así es que el lado
derecho tenemos tan solo w y el lado
izquierdo así se queda y ya hemos
acabado si giramos si invertimos esta
ecuación tenemos entonces que
p - 2 l
y todo eso pm 2 l dividido entre 2 ahora
esta es la respuesta correcta la fórmula
que nos piden sin embargo hay otra
manera de escribirla esto lo puedes
escribir como déjame primero marcar esto
porque definitivamente esto es una
respuesta válida a lo que nos están
pidiendo esta es la respuesta correcta
pero hay otras maneras de escribir esta
fórmula tú también podrías haber hecho
lo siguiente que es un camino también
válido para llegar a la solución déjame
hacerlo por acá nuestra fórmula original
es p es igual a 2 l2 w qué tal si factor
izamos ahora el 2 de esta expresión a
ver hagámoslo claro porque aquí tenemos
un 2 y aquí tenemos otro 2 podemos
factorizar 2 del lado derecho así es que
nos queda que es igual a 2 vamos a
factorizar ese 2 que multiplica
el más wv que quede claro este también
es un camino válido para despejar w muy
bien que nos queda ahora podemos dividir
entre 2 ambos lados dividimos entre 2 a
ambos lados de la ecuación del lado
derecho 2 arriba y 2 abajo se cancelan y
del lado izquierdo
nos queda simplemente t sobre 2 que
tenemos ahora tenemos del lado izquierdo
p sobre 2
sobre dos lo cual es igual a l más
w ahora para despejar w restamos l ambos
lados y lo puedes hacer de varias
maneras lo puede ser como aquí en una
línea distinta o si no lo puedes hacer
directamente sobre la ecuación entonces
restando l del lado derecho y también
del lado izquierdo sumamos - l
que es lo mismo bien del lado derecho l
menos l se cancelan con lo cual ya quedó
despejada w
ya tenemos w y del lado izquierdo que
nos queda nos queda menos l más p sobre
2 o podemos usar la conmuta tividad de
la suma para escribir esto como p sobre
2 t sobre 2 - l y ésta también es una
respuesta totalmente válida y tú me
podrías decir oye sal esto se ve
totalmente distinto
p - 2 l sobre 2 se ve diferente que p
sobre 2 - l pero no son distintas
veámoslo aquí esto lo podemos escribir
como como p
déjame ponerlo mejor con el color que
tiene originalmente esto es p sobre 2
sobre 2 - 2 l
sobre 2 - 2 cl sobre 2 estoy separando
simplemente esta resta que sobre 2 - 2 l
sobre 2 ahora aquí tenemos 2 l sobre 2
estos 12 se pueden simplificar con lo
cual nos queda
p sobre 2 p sobre 2 - el peso sobre 2 l
lo cual es exactamente lo que habíamos
obtenido acá